alexandre et son remplacement par george
shultz interprété comme un durcissement
de la politique étrangère américaine
espace la première journée en orbite de
l'équipage franco soviétique wimbledon à
tennis gorgés de pluie et un tournoi
engagés
madame monsieur bonsoir c'est un coup de
tonnerre qui a éclaté hier soir à
washington
et l'actualité internationale
aujourd'hui en voici encore le
secrétaire d'état avec alexander haig
n'a plus la charge de la diplomatie
américaine en pleine crise libanaise
à quelques jours de l'ouverture de
négociations sur la réduction des
armements stratégiques avec l'union
soviétique alexandre aig a présenté sa
démission et le président reagan l'a
acceptée très ému il a annoncé aux
journalistes convoquée en toute hâte
dans la salle de presse de la maison
blanche
à 9 heures du soir heure française
alexandre rey devait ensuite au
département d'état lire sa lettre de
démission
et le monde en dénonçant ainsi les
déviations de la politique étrangère
américaine du cours prudent qu'il
voulait lui imprimer alexandre v qui
plusieurs fois déjà avait menacé de
démissionner laissant entendre que ce
sont les partisans d'une autre ligne qui
l'ont emporté ce qu'ils font partie du
clan des californiens proches de
monsieur reggane et auquel appartient de
fait le successeur désigné
george shultz de washington edouard nord
une fois passé l'information brute et
l'effet de bombes qu'elle a causés ici à
washington
on mesure un peu plus ce matin toute la
signification d'un changement de tête
ici même au département d'état à
washington d'abord parce qu'il s'agit
avant tout d'une opération de politique
intérieure au delà du départ d'alexandre
de règles il faut je crois regardez
maintenant vers le successeur george
shultz un ami intime du secrétaire à la
défense caspar weinberger californien
comme lui qui ont travaillé ensemble
longtemps dans le privé et qui partagent
les mêmes idées autant d'éléments qui
concrétise aujourd'hui dans
l'administration reagan
ce qu'on appelle ici le clan des
californiens deuxième point la politique
étrangère américaine george schultz ce
n'est un secret pour personne
un objectif prioritaire comme celui de
van berg r l'anti moscou on peut donc
facilement imaginer une radicalisation
la diplomatie américaine qui pourrait
commencer par la confirmation de
l'extension des sanctions annoncées la
semaine dernière par le président reagan
sur la sphère du gazoduc
jusqu au proche orient où le soutien
inconditionnel d'alexander et à israël
dans la sphère du liban pourrait bien
être remis en question dans les
prochains jours enfin pour la petite
histoire on murmure ici au département
d'état que c'était la cinquième ou la
sixième lettre de démission qu alexander
haig a choisi de la présenter au plus
fort de la crise du liban en pensant
le président allait la refuser mais que
compte tenu de l'état des relations
entre alexander haig et l'état-major de
la maison blanche
on a le regan a sauté sur l'occasion
relation qui en fait ne date pas d'hier
due essentiellement à la personnalité de
l'alexander aig et dont l'ambition avait
profondément choqué les américains
notamment et je vous propose de revoir
cette image le jour de l'attentât contre
le président alexandre de rake s'est
présenté quelques instants plus tard
avec cette phrase à partir de maintenant
je prend les affaires en main ici à la
maison blanche oui le tempérament
bouillant d'alexandre et qui à 57 ans de
l'armée à la politique n'a cessé
d'affirmer sa réputation d'homme pressé
ce tempérament ses convictions et son
expérience de l'europe en particulier
avait provoqué à plusieurs reprises des
affrontements violents avec ses
collègues de l'équipe reggane accrochage
avec le premier conseiller pour les
affaires de sécurité richard allen dont
il obtint la démission accrochage avec
le second le californien claque
accrochage avec l' ambassadeur aux
nations unies van hamme kirk patrick sur
la crise des malouines accrochages
continuent surtout avec son grand rival
le patron du pentagone gaspard wahlberg
est partisan d'une ligne plus dure
vis-à-vis de moscou et vis-à-vis de
l'europe
dernier épisode en date la décision
présidentielle selon l'avis de johan
burger et contraire d'empêcher les
filiales européennes de sociétés
américaines de participer à l'équipement
du gazoduc soviétique
le nouveau chef de la diplomatie
américaine jazz soul 61 ans que vous
voyez ici un tout autre profil
californien patron jusqu'ici d'une
grande société de construction qui
travaille beaucoup en arabie saoudite
george schultz avait déjà mis ses
compétences économiques au service des
administrations eisenhower et nixon ils
étaient plusieurs fois ministre il était
en fait le premier choix du président
reagan au début de son administration
pour le poste des affaires étrangères
mais il avait préféré rester dans le
privé en tant que conseiller personnel
du président il avait le mois dernier en
europe préparer la tournée du président
américain
c'est donc un grand commis de l'état à
l'américaine
il prend la tête du département d'état
et les réactions des grandes preuves des
grandes capitales à sa nomination
s'accordent sur une même interprétation
avec monsieur schulz c'est une ligne
plus dure vis-à-vis de moscou surtout
qui va être appliqué à moscou pas de
réaction officielle mais une méfiance
accrue comme nous l'expliquent patrick
meney pour moscou la démission du
secrétaire d'état américain ne pouvait
pas tomber plus mal
elle intervient à la veille de la
reprise des négociations sur le
désarmement
elle coïncide également avec un léger
mieux dans les relations m
ouais juste au moment où alexander haig
venait de rencontrer andré gromyko les
soviétiques qui ont horreur des
changements politiques d'autant plus
inquiet que le secrétaire d'état leur
part été moins dure vis-à-vis de lui
répète qu ronald reagan
le kremlin redoutent la possibilité
d'une nouvelle vague anti soviétique de
la part de washington
c'est pourquoi lui réfère va désormais
miser sur le dialogue roues plus haut
niveau c'est à dire sur le sommet
fraîche date reagan en octobre prochain
pour les alliés européens des états unis
à commencer par l'allemagne fédérale le
changement d'homme à la tête de la
diplomatie américaine paraît tout aussi
lourd de conséquences de bonnes michel
meyer la victoire des faucons des durs
de l'équipe reggane est perçu à travers
cette démission cette éviction du
général aig et l'on s'attend bien
entendu à l'articulation par et weinberg
où les clark d'une politique américaine
beaucoup plus ferme beaucoup plus dur
par rapport à l'union soviétique et
cette politique de confrontation qui
envisage notamment d'utiliser l'armé
économique comme moyen de mettre à
genoux les soviétiques
eh bien elle n'est pas du tout apprécié
à bonn où l'on s'efforce au maximum de
croire à un reste de détente et d'éviter
en tout cas tout regard de guerre froide
ne serait ce que pour ne pas perturber
les relations élémentaire humanitaire
avec les autres frères allemands avec
l'allemagne de l'est
sur le plan économique bien entendu il y
a également des intérêts qui sont en
cause
et à cet égard on peut s'attendre à une
attitude très ferme des allemands par
rapport aux américains sur la question
des importations de gaz ce biais
tic à cet égard l uci mythe entend
utiliser au maximum la solidarité des
européens la solidarité d'intérêt les
européens pour articuler par rapport aux
américains une sorte de front commun que
l'on définira très vraisemblablement vu
de bonnes en tout cas à bruxelles lors
du prochain sommet européen
à paris c'est aussi la surprise et la
même inquiétude on souligne pourtant au
quai d'orsay que monsieur schulz connaît
bien les pays européens et leur position
sur les dossiers économiques qui
envenime les rapports avec les états
unis et qui doivent donc être discutées
lundi à bruxelles en conseil européen ce
changement de visage et peut-être de
ligne de la diplomatie américaine
intervient en plein conflit libanais ce
qui n'a pas empêché les états unis la
nuit dernière de prouver la continuité
de son soutien à israël
les etats unis ont en effet voté contre
le projet de résolution français au
consensus et qui sont en faveur du
projet de résolution
publié sous la cote s 15le 155 révision
2 et corrigée dans les termes que j'ai
dit dans mon intervention tout à l'heure
veille bien levé la main
ceux qui sont content
du projet qui visait la neutralisation
de verres ou plus étaient trop vagues
quant aux modalités de l'évacuation des
forces palestiniennes et de la remise de
leurs armes
paris regrette décision américaine les
pays arabes la condamne à jérusalem
c'est le chaud froid satisfaction à
l'annoncé du veto américain
mes regrets officielle du départ
d'alexandre jung et vive inquiétude
quant au lien arabe de son successeur de
jérusalem gérard ce bague satisfaction
israël après le veto américain aux
nations unies où l'on considère que la
position de la france est de plus en
plus pro palestinienne
cette satisfaction est tout de même
doublé d'une légère inquiétude après le
départ de monsieur règles et de son
remplacement par monsieur schultz
considéré ici comme très proche du lobby
pro arabe aux etats-unis
sa société vit-on la société bechtel à
des contrats très importants en cours en
arabie saoudite
et l'on n'oublie pas que lui-même avait
demandé à la suite du bombardement de la
centrale nucléaire irakienne des
sanctions contre israël mais pour autant
les israéliens ne semble pas décidé à
lâcher le morceau
les commentateurs politiques affirment
que le gouvernement israélien va
maintenant aller encore plus vite
justement avant que le nouveau
secrétaire américain prenne ses
fonctions
ils réaffirment leur volonté de faire
partir l'ol paie du liban
le cessez-le-feu d'aujourd'hui n'est qu'
un dernier répit pour monsieur aviv le
médiateur américain et l'on rapporte
d'ailleurs le dernier entretien de
monsieur philippe à vide avec des
dirigeants israéliens
à la question qui êtes vous prêt à
accorder à l'ol paie la réponse a été la
seule chose que nous sommes prêts à
accorder à l'ol paie c'est la vie sauve
mais cette position intransigeante du
gouvernement israélien est de plus en
plus mal acceptée par une frange de la
population
d'ailleurs ce soir à tel-aviv a lieu une
grande manifestation du mouvement la
paix maintenant contre cette invasion au
liban c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire d'israël qu'une manifestation
de ce type a lieu en pleine guerre alors
qu'une partie des réservistes sont
encore sur le front sur le terrain à
beyrouth le cessez le feu accepté hier
soir par israël après un dernier
pilonnage
en cif le cessez-le-feu a été respectée
aujourd'hui le point de la situation ce
soir de beyrouth danielle cattelin
entassés dans l'envié 28 du linge et des
matelas et bombardé emprunter un peu
partout l'enfant la mère d ilan 205
consommer la panique parmi la population
aujourd'hui encore prévient ont survolé
la capitale libanaise
je rappelle qu'on attend de beyrouth que
les biens sont toujours là selon la
radio israélienne le temps du
négociateur avec un philippin vivait
désormais compté pour obtenir une
solution diplomatique
s'il ne parvient pas à arracher aux
palestiniens leur édition est aussi rien
à leur départ israël s'en chargera tout
seul dit on dans l'entourage du premier
ministre israël et les palestiniens ne
se rendront pas à philippe habibou
déclare de son côté le président de l'ol
paie yasser arafat
anna en fait curieusement souriant qu'il
a affirmé sa détermination hier à la
télévision britannique
m
si hier un message de monsieur brejnev
lui confirmant le soutien de l'urss
à l'occasion de la visite à moscou du
roi hussein de jordanie
moscou a réaffirmé aujourd'hui à
destination des pays arabes
sa condamnation de l'opération
israélienne au liban
l'actualité en france maintenant une
actualité politique ralenti en cette fin
de semaine sauf pour les responsables de
l'udf
ils se sont réunis aujourd'hui à paris
pour une journée d'étude consacrée
essentiellement à la préparation des
élections municipales
serge me serais surmonter les
dissensions internes présenté partout
des listes d'union dès le premier tour
tel est le devoir de vacances proposé à
la centaine de délégués réunis porte de
serre avec pour thème de réflexion
comment réhabiliter l'image de marque du
parti dans le pays
pas question donc pour l'instant de se
réunir sous une quelconque bannière
d'homme providentiel dit michel pinton
sous-entendu giscard-chirac face au rpr
qui demande que l'on prenne en compte
les résultats depuis les dernières
municipales pour la constitution de
listes d'union jean lecanuet répond il
faut d'abord battre la majorité n'est
pas pour le plaisir de l'abattre et ans
pour nous pour servir les français qui
sont maintenant dans une un plat mais
pour cela il faut se dire avec leurs
pairs horvat à ravoir rpr soit donne
l'impression de vouloir tailler la part
du lion
le week-end ça c'est votre
interprétation
vous vous adressez à un maire et l'union
se fait commune par commune
village par village pour par bourg
grandes villes par grandes villes en
fonction de quoi que des réalités
locales des personnalités qui ont la
confiance de leurs concitoyens alors
c'est ainsi qu'on va faire ces élections
en réunissant 2 12 administrateurs et en
montrant évidemment les graves erreurs
ou la france est engagée par la gestion
socialo communiste ce sera donc en même
temps un grand débat politique c'est
vrai mais comment allez vous faire pour
harmoniser les violons avec le rpr
mais il n'ya pas les harmoniser ils
jouent bien croyez le et vous le
constaterez vous l'avez vous aux
cantonales
un sondage qui vient à point sur un
thème qui servira sans doute de cheval
de bataille et à l'opposition pour ces
municipales l'enseignement libre
69% des français sont pour selon madame
figaro
les employeurs vont désormais
subventionner jusqu'à un certain point
les transports en commun l'assemblée
nationale a en effet adopté la nuit
dernière le projet de loi qui vise à
faire prendre en charge par les
employeurs 40% du coût de la carte
orange
en tout cas en région parisienne en
contrepartie il n'y a plus de prime de
transport
l'enquète de gens payent eux un bureau
d'aidé sociale à paris une des rares
villes à rembourser leurs transports
publics aux chômeurs en l'occurrence la
carte orange de zone à partir du 1er
octobre
c'est l'ensemble des salariés
d'ile-de-france qui se feront rembourser
40 % de leur carte orange ou
hebdomadaire par leur employeur
mais l'employeur pourra choisir une
autre formule il achète lui-même les
cartes à la ratp ou sncf et les revend à
ses employés à 60 % de leur valeur au
prix actuel une carte hebdomadaire
coûtera au visage et 25 cents de moins
par mois
une carte orange 5 zone 92 francs et
après la hausse prévue en octobre
100 francs de moins auto et deux roues y
perdront la prime de 23 francs et en
supprimer la loi peut en effet encouragé
les transports en commun un million
quatre cent mille personnes utilisent
aujourd'hui la carte orange
les pouvoirs publics espérant gagner 250
milles de plus dans cette entreprise de
colombes
la moitié des salariés utilisent un
transport personnel les autres un
transport collectif
la nouvelle loi n'aura pas les mêmes
conséquences pour les uns et les autres
qu'elle mangeait bête accueil et en
transport jeu ça me revient par mois à 3
137 francs bien sûr avec la prime dès
qu'on taise on touche les îles 40% sur
le feu total je vais gagner à peu près
90 francs celle de la somme totale
moi je devais 35 à 40 minutes pour venir
par l'autoroute alors qu'avec les
chemins de fer et je les trouve et
l'autre 1,2 fois le train et une fois le
métro il me faudrait au moins deux
heures vous aurez vous allez perdre 23
francs de transport ben oui ça c'est
violent qu'est ce que vous les jeux
précédents bourse a pu voyager
rapidement et tranquillement
actuellement outre la prime de 23 francs
les employeurs ayant plus de neuf
salariés paient un versement transport
proportionnelle au salaire le total
couvre les quatre cinquièmes du coût
réel du transport usagers et pouvoirs
publics payants le reste à terme le
gouvernement souhaite que les employeurs
paient la totalité de ce coup le
remboursement à 40 % des titres de
transport ne coûtera pas plus cher
globalement à l'ensemble des entreprises
que la prime de 23 francs supprimé par
la loi à 50% dans un an les employeurs
paieront 250 millions de plus à 80% dans
trois ans 950 millions de plus à
colombes
en tout cas selon le pdg les charges de
l'entreprise augmenteront d'un cinquième
ça va plutôt rigidifier le rapprochement
entre l'employeur et le demandeur
d'emploi car ça va très sorte de
contrainte le vampire va sylvain suis là
si je dois payer 200 à 300 francs de
taxes de carte orange
je pense que ça va pas soupire le
rapprochement de du demandeur d'emploi
et de l'emploi hier le voulait dire vous
ne serez pas tenté d'embaucher des gens
qui habiteront trop loin c'est une chose
qui risque d'être prise en considération
ce risque le ministre accepte de le
courir le but essentiel étant de
rapprocher domicile et travail mais
inciter les gens à prendre davantage des
transports publics exige qu on les
améliore
or la ratp est couverte de dettes le
gouvernement sera donc contraint à payer
à l'heure de l'austérité pourtant ça ne
sera pas facile
oui en région parisienne le projet de
loi abaisse de 100 milles à 30000
habitants le seuil pour la participation
des employeurs aux frais des transports
en commun ils sont cinq maintenant à
tourner au dessus de nous jean loup
chrétien et 4 spationautes soviétique
depuis la jonction réussi hier soir de
la fusée soyouz à la station orbitale
saliou t'occuper déjà par deux hommes
depuis plus de cinq semaines
ils doivent réaliser ensemble une série
d'expériences scientifiques
georges leclercq est à moscou et vous
venez georges d'entrer en communication
avec jean loup chrétien
ma femme elle vous êtes en direction à
peine deux ans aux commandes vocales
on va très bien vous avez joué un peu
gonflé c'est le bonheur de l'espace qui
voulait le faire avant qu'elle n'ait
jamais pu reporter
non
jean loïc l'eau sur paris ce que pour
moscou mais vues de ce tacle était
respectée vaut quand même écouter bleus
m
mais quand même
j'avais jean-loup tout à l'heure il ya
environ ils ont dit vous avez fait une
transmission scientifique et tout le
monde ici a été stupéfait par la qualité
de vos observations nouveaux coéquipiers
à toulouse vous remercie mon voudrais
aussi vous demander qu'est ce qui va
vous parler d'expérience sur cet envol
donnerait des années si on la perd le
plus rapidement possible
on l'entend dans le mais il est loin
demain la navette spatiale américaine
columbia prendra le départ pour la
quatrième fois ce sera le dernier vol
d'essai de mise au point du vaisseau
spatial réutilisable dont la vocation
sera surtout militaire la justice sur
terre ou plutôt la justice en france les
magistrats adhérents à lui s aiment le
plus gros est le moins à gauche des
syndicats de magistrats en discute en ce
moment en avignon
la vocation du projet de loi sécurité et
liberté ne suscite pas l'enthousiasmé
chez les magistrats
malgré la plaidoirie que leur fille
tiers le garde des sceaux robert
badinter en avignon peut le faire au
congrès c'est sans conteste le fameux
questionnaire dont les réponses se
dessine le profil de l'avancée de la
magistrature actuellement en france la
loi sécurité et liberté tout n'y est pas
mis latif il faut l'aménager et non pas
la brochure la démocratisation la
justice les textes actuels sont
suffisants ce qu'il faut c'est celle des
moyens pour les appliquer le tribunal de
l'exécution des peines ils sont plutôt
pour mais contre en tout cas la
suppression des courtes peines et la
suppression de la détention provisoire
des mineurs ce qui ne veut pas dire que
les magistrats presque sont satisfaits
de la situation actuelle
réponse du garde des sceaux voici
qu'elle a ma conception de la
magistrature en un mot que les palais de
justice aussi ne soit plus seulement des
forums ou qu'ils retrouvent leur
véritable dimension au delà de
l'institut conflit judiciaire d'efforts
oui mais à la condition que ce soir des
forums ouverts à réciter ouvrait vers
indépendamment des règles de publicité
des débats
verzy venir nos concitoyens selon les
initiatives qu'il appartient à chaque
juridiction de prendre celle à faire de
chacune
cela se résout sur place mais soyez une
magistrature présente est ouvert
c'est dans la cité c'est essentiel pour
le devenir de l'institution c'est
capital pour que les français sentent
que leur magistrature est proche
humainement aussi de même dans le
quotidien de leur vie le sport
maintenant pas de mundial aujourd'hui
ouf diront certains deux jours de trêve
avant le début lundi du deuxième tour en
revanche il y a eu un quart c'est
aujourd'hui pire adressé n'y en aura
demain oui alors que si je vais vous
donner les résultats du prix de castries
le tir sec et secouristes a promis des
longchamps arriver donc 3 5 6 qui
rapportent dans l'ordre pour 500 3767
francs 50 et dans un ordre différent
toujours pour 5 francs 753 francs 50
voilà demain toujours longchamp et bien
vous pourrez tenter une fois de plus
votre chance dans le tiercé qui se
déroulera à lui dans le prix major
fridolin voilà il y aura c'est une
course à handicap longue de 2000 mètres
il y aura dix neuf partants des mâles et
des femelles âgées de 3 ans parmi eux
j'ai remarqué duc d'aubry entraînée par
françois doumen d'icd aubry vient de
gagner sur 1800 mètres il abordera pour
la première fois deux mille mètres que
je pense qu'il peut le faire tout de
suite je vous présente du de bruit une
interview de françois doumen son
entraîneur bon c'est un cheval qui était
finalement assez méconnu par le public
parce que c'est un c'est un cheval qui a
été tellement souvent battue mais battu
second et surtout à son aîné de deux ans
battu second part toujours de très bons
chevaux vous attendez quelques
performances sa part dimanche pense
qu'il devrait pouvoir être à l'arrivée
c'est sacha qui très régulier il et il
n'y a qu'une fois où il m'a déçu
c'était le premier tiers c'est que j'ai
couru début de l'année il n'avait pas
encore les oeillères il avait vraiment
eu très peur de ce nombre peloton et il
n'avait pas du tout fait sa performance
ce jour là il faut pas la juger sur
cette course là il avait pressenti pour
cent à le faire venir vers nous et on va
y arriver il est carrément il est gentil
vous savez c'est un certain aaron duke
ce sont des graphistes de six crans
brown duke et ce sont les chevaux qui
sont très dures alors bon papa voilà
dans le pronostic que je vous propose
maintenant j'ai choisi de passer en tête
chauny like ensuite by guillaume jan o
minute qui vient de gagner à evry en
site cristal de lune monté par
l'excellent jean pierre camani river
valley et brighton et les outsiders
vous êtes dette les zips hausse est due
tout gris portant le numéro 12 4 6 7 11
un sac voilà merci peps les britanniques
ont appris à faire de la pluie un charme
complémentaire de l'existence mais cette
fois c'est trop
à wimbledon les organisateurs sont
désespérés plus 120 partis en retard
dans le grand tournoi international de
tennis sur gazon il pleut sous un
parapluie daniel cazelles il est 12h
visite à londres par billie jean king et
tania rapport d'entamer leur rencontre
il est 17 heures 55 ans le match se
termine sur la victoire en trois sets de
l'américaine alors 5 heures 45 minutes
de jeu non seulement 1h55
le reste c'est la pluie par trois fois
aujourd'hui
les rencontres ont été interrompues par
des averses diluviennes
le scénario ne marie pas les joueurs se
replient vers les vestiaires les
ramasseurs de balles cèdent la place aux
ramasseurs de bâches et le public
stoïque se réfugient sous les parapluies
si bien que le retard ce soir risque
fort d'être d'environ 170 matches alors
wimbledon terminera-t-il dans les délais
ou est ainsi répond freinrail le juge
arbitre il ne perd pas son calme tout en
reconnaissant qu'il n'a encore jamais vu
pareille chose
le mauvais temps a également des
répercussions sur l'affluence wimbledon
pour sa première semaine enregistre 50
mille entrées de moins qu en 81
ce sont les populaires debout à trois
livres qui sont boudés
cela se traduit par un million huit cent
mille francs de pertes sèches par
rapport à l'année dernière mais peut-on
raisonnablement parler de perte sèche
quand le ciel déverse des promos sur
wimbledon elle à gillot pétré il faut
faire quelque chose pour les
britanniques vous en avez déjà
l'élégance avec votre costume trois
pièces se soit trop c'est trop et moi je
ne peux rien des trombes d'eau s'est
peut-être un peu beaucoup
enfin je suis j'ai le plaisir à nos cd v
cazals qui ça va continuer à pleuvoir
demain et que dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi une nouvelle perturbation arrivera
sur l'europe et donc sur wimbledon pas
pas fini d'en parler
cela dit écoutez bien 36° à rome 44
degrés en sardaigne 40° athènes 48
degrés en test
li en grèce et oui c'est très très chaud
mais 14° à dinard à 16 heures maximum 28
à marseille pour aujourd'hui si ce n'est
pas du soleil frais qu'est ce je vous le
demande
soleil ferai demain sur tout le pays
beau temps tout de même sur le sud est
avec un mistral et une tramontane qui
vont dégager les nuages ils vont les
pousser et les orages ont les poussines
à l'italie sa rafraîchir à l'italie les
éclaircies seront de plus en plus belle
par l'ouest en cours de journée mais
tout de même au nord de la loire une
grande partie de la journée le ciel sera
toujours variable instable freiner vent
les températures ça vaut le détour tout
à l'heure avec des rafales de nord ouest
forte sur les côtes de la manche mais
également à l'intérieur des rafales de
l'ouest sur la sur l'atlantique
passages nuageux accompagnés d'averses
les orages seront de plus en plus rares
il devrait plus y en avoir et bien
entendu dans tout cela il y aura quand
même quelques éclaircies
alors les températures je découvre très
lentement pour que vous puissiez voir ça
c'est la dégringolade générale c'est en
baisse partout maximum 20 degrés un
basket investia ski quand même encore
tout à fait convenable minimum 16 degrés
mais oui j'ai bien dit 16-16 à limoges
et a clairement si l'on fait la moyenne
de tout ce qui reste on obtient 18
degrés au maximum autant vous dire que
ce sont les températures qui sont très
largement en dessous des normes
saisonnières on devrait avoir nettement
plus chaud demain dimanche 27 juin une
minute de sommeil en moins par dessus le
marché
levet 5h51 coucher 21h56 et bonne fête à
tous les ferments à 23h15 c'était avec
l'autre qui vous présentera notre
dernier journal je vous rappelle les
deux principaux titres ce soir veto
américain au conseil de sécurité des
nations unies contre le projet français
de neutralisation de beyrouth-ouest
cessez le feu respecté aujourd'hui
et puis la démission d'alexandre reggae
l'arrivée de george shultz changement
d'homme et peut-être de ligne pour la
politique étrangère américaine
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal à demain
20 heures